oh look at this dramatic lighting how
perfect since I have a genetic model for
you it's national chip and dip day
that's it I know you are welcome for
that piece of Education and information
finally the Internet is rewarding you
there's a bug the other day I looked up
daily holidays and found out that today
is National Chip and dip Day one website
said that and that's enough for me not
only is the National Chip and dip day I
recently went to a Tony Robbins
conference those two things wouldn't
normally go together but today they do
because I'm forcing them together like
all of the collaborations that ever done
because of you that do not know Tony
Robbins is a very popular self-help life
coach a mentor intelligent powerful
energetic human being one of my most
favorite dips is a seven-layer Mexican
dip if that doesn't scream needy I don't
know what I can't have one dip I want
seven of them all at once
but then I'll probably only eat the
guacamole out of him in addition to that
one of Tony's founding principles is
that all human beings have six needs I
know this seems completely all over the
place but I figured stay with me for a
second that was the original title of
stay with me they thought that it sounds
a little desperate
love tony has developed a very basic
list of the six human needs that drive
all of us to do what we do it is not
only an enjoyable and easy to make food
item but it can be an educational tool
how could I combine the six human needs
with a seven-layer Mexican dip Oh police
are coming because I've been taking so
long
to explain this I'm sorry I stole your
time here alone so today I'm creating
for you a six layer needy Mexican dip I
didn't think of a title is what just
occurred to me did my [ __ ] like this dip
is my [ __ ]
I love this dip but also this dip
represent my [ __ ] like all the reasons
that I don't live my best life and also
like dip my [ __ ] this dip kind of looks
like fecal matter even the title has so
many layers but please don't hesitate to
give me a better suggestion for a title
of this dip in the comments I winked at
you Oh am i leaving with desperation
right now yes Bart we also did not think
through the actual construction and
education process of this
I'm not following the recipe for this
six layer Mexican dish I'm just going
with what I think should be in this
Mexican dish for human need welcome all
lady I made this guacamole I have a
video on my channel you can watch right
here if you want to see how I made
welcome Olie or you can watch this very
abbreviated version the first we need a
clear container because the best thing
about a layer dip is that you can see
all of the layers it's like you grow as
a person when you become a little bit
more transparent do not send new photos
to anyone via text message so do not
confuse those ideas our first layer is
guacamole and guacamole represents whoa
which is one of our final human needs
smells it is exactly what it sounds like
to have the need to evolve to expand
your capabilities I think welcome only
represents growth because children don't
like guacamole but a lot of basics
adults do myself included and so as you
grow older you grow away more fond of
guacamole and think that it's good it
I'll play the educational process of
this gets better as we go along move
along quickly next layer screaming get
education cross all the next layer is
salsa you can make your own salsa if you
have a need for significance we'll get
to that later I'm using canned salsa &
salsa represents certainty okay
certainty needs to hear driven by t or
assurance
our stability you need to know what's up
and know that that is not going to
change also represent certainty because
it's pretty guaranteed that salsa is
gonna be salsa regardless of whether you
buy it or make it it's salsa certainty
salsa in an x-ray by means should be
should probably get cooked
dammit me shigeko alright the opposite
need of certainty is variety right it
means that you are led by a need to
change your state for your environment
you drive off of change
I thought refried beans best represented
variety because there's no certainty in
what these will do to your body
that's easy job maybe I forgot to
explain why knowing the sixth human
needs is important oops knowing the six
human needs and knowing primarily which
- you almost driven by in your actions
of reactions to people and things can
really help you figure out why you do
what you do you get upset when someone
changes plans because you're driven by
certainty and need to know exactly
what's happening you get upset when your
partner doesn't want to have a
spontaneous trip over the weekend
because you're driven by variety he's
being seemed done oh wow its mission
next player this it's probably not
making any sense to anyone that's layer
it Oh a very interesting layer meat this
is fake meat feel free to use regular
meat it doesn't make you happy or feel
free to continue you know me about my
food choices if that's what makes you
happy
let's heat this up meat layer of this
dip represent a human need for
significance the human need for
significance is a very dangerous and
tricky needs were driven by the feeling
of being special or unique or
interesting usually what we're all
driven by on YouTube I thought a meat
layer was best to represent significance
because meat in a dip screams that you
are trying to be unique and interesting
I'm going to keep up this meat in a
skillet with a little bit of garlic and
a little bit of enchilada sauce
Oh wall are significant meat that's a
really great name for a male stripper
significant body could barely handle it
all are significant meat heats up let's
move on to our next layer which is sour
cream our sour cream level represents
the need for contributions
we're driven by the need to contribute
to others and or to feel contribution
from others towards yourself sour cream
I thought that's represented that
because some cream is best wooded just
paired with other things eating sour
cream alone it's not best you contribute
very well to meals on your own you're
curious player okay Wow yes Wow our meat
is good enough now we're going to put
our significance on top of contribution
Wow and the last layer in our sixth
layer needy Mexican dip is cheese cheese
represents the human need for love and
connection because who doesn't love
cheese and where can't warm with
connection based on their love of cheese
or their digestive systems ability to
not digest cheese the human need of love
and connection is like all the rest of
them kind of self-explanatory you are
driven by a need to feel loved or give
love or to feel connected and there we
have it our six layer needy Mexican dip
and or dips my [ __ ] once you've created
your six layer needy mix and dip let
people dig in and see what they are
they're most attracted to you can find
out which needs their most led by
there's no guarantees that the outcome
of your experiment is accurate to that
actual person and/or their needs however
it's a fun way to mentally and feed them
at the same time what was the point of
this video happy oh wait you should try
this Jesus happy chicken dip day and
happy self-evaluation which needs your
most led by and might as you have
epiphanies as to why you do what you do
why you do the things you don't like
that you doing etcetera etcetera etc
good luck with your existential crisis
basically it
if I don't know why is there not a
grocery store called
go with your gut oh right because it's
really a stupid name got it
I'll just be here those first in this
writ onion